dr. mona hanna-attisha is a pediatrician
at Flint's public hospital she was the
first person to scientifically prove a
direct link between Flint's 2014 water
switch and elevated levels of lead in
the local children her new book is
called what the eyes don't see a story
of crisis resistance and hope in an
American city she calls Flint a crime
scene and says the city has PTSD from
the water disaster a disaster she says
could have been prevented dr.
hanna-attisha joins us at the table good
morning to you good morning Gail this
became such a personal story for you I
know that you know after reading your
book you lost weight you lost sleep
because you had been telling your young
patients and their mothers it's okay to
drink this tap water
absolutely so kids would come into
clinics their parents would ask is the
water okay can I give this to my child
can I mix my baby's formula with with
this water and we were reassuring them
yes it's okay how could the water that
comes out of your tap not be okay so how
did you find out there was a problem so
it happened very much by serendipity I
was at home with a high school
girlfriend drinking a glass of wine
having a barbecue my high school
girlfriend Elin happens to be a water
expert and she was the first person who
mentioned to me that the water wasn't
being treated properly and because of
that there would be lead in the water
your research found that the lead levels
in children's blood doubled and even
tripled after this 2014 switch in the
river water how did that occur explain
the biology behind it absolutely so the
Flint water wasn't treated properly so
it was leeching lead into the drinking
water which got into the bodies of our
children and the blood led data that we
looked at was based on screening data
which is done at the ages of 1 & 2 when
you worry about lead in dust and soil
and paint not lead in water because it
significantly retards brain development
yes so lead is a known potent
irreversible neurotoxin it impacts
cognition IQ levels behavior we now know
based on incredible science there is no
safe level of lead exposure at all yeah
and in a small part - but so many people
knew about this Mona that's the thing
when you raise the flag your call
irresponsible unfortunate researcher
causing near hysteria splicing and
dicing
the numbers yeah so lots of folks knew
about this crisis there was many many
red flags just a few months after we
switched this water source General
Motors which was born in Flint stopped
using this water because it was
corroding engine parts so imagine that
corroding engine parts what's it doing
to our plumbing what was it like to go
through that period where your drum
being discredited in public in American
life right now there are a lot of people
who are who are not speaking up are
trying to speak up and there are big
forces against them so what was it like
being inside of that for yes it was it
was hard it was traumatic my heart rate
went up my might I was shaking I just
wanted to hide under the covers for a
moment but but then I realized that it's
it's my professional professional my
morale my ethical obligation to speak up
for these kids I'm a pediatrician I
literally took an oath to protect
children to be their healer to make sure
that they're not only healthy today but
that they're healthy forever so you know
I all my research was based on numbers
and statistics but every number was a
kid a kid who who I probably took care
of and and that's what inspired me to
speak up in that piece we saw people
still have concerns about the water in
Flint should they absolutely
this isn't as a loss of trust in Flint
for for so long they were betrayed by
really every government agency that was
that was meant to protect them would you
drink the water there I now knowing
about kind of federal standards about
letting water
I don't drink unfiltered water anywhere
our policies nationally especially the
lead and copper rule are too weak they
have not caught up with a science of no
safe level of lead all right doctor
we're gonna have to end it there dr.
mona hanna-attisha thanks Emma thank you
so much what the eyes don't see is on
sale now